lauren good morning will judd pete well
why the daylight hours at that march
remained largely peaceful with tens of
thousands of pro-trump supporters
it was after the sun went down that
things took a much
uglier tone fireworks fireworks
fireworks
counter protesters clashed with those
who turned out for the president even
throwing fireworks there were fistfights
to all out brawls which stretched into
the early hours this morning
overall there were 20 arrests according
to the mayor's office and at least seven
guns were recovered
one man was stabbed he is expected to be
all right
here's the breakdown of at least 10
arrests made earlier yesterday they
included firearm violations simple
assault
assault on an officer and disorderly
contact the president tweeted about the
chaos writing
radical left antifa scum was easily
rebuffed today by the big dc
maga rally crowd only to return at night
after 99 percent of the crowd had
left to assault elderly people and
families
police got there but late mayor is not
doing her
job we're also told there were two
police officers who were injured and
were hoping for an update later on this
morning if there were any additional
arrests and any additional injuries
back to you guys thanks lauren